auf und davon spezial wird ihnen
präsentiert von kinder schokolade
vor 60 jahren ist familie denn zum abruf
florida noch cape coral
[Musik]
denn das geschäft aufgemacht sie
formierten ferien ist gut gelaufen so
gut dass sie gleich nach ihrer ankunft
in wilna um zu gesicht
jetzt trifft es wieder turbulent die
ziethe liege die hinteren kurpark
discovery sechs oder kleid einen neuen
job
und larissa ist bald wieder singen
maschine schloss
aber ich bleibe ein kleines spielzeug
make hochdruckreiniger geräte gehen
[Musik]
ziel ist es bis dahin die kasse
florida besucher start vor mary kay ray
of live so entspannt wie der familie
[Musik]
ludmilla hieße das dass die high von der
familie denn zu viel
ich werte die die entboten gegangen
ungezwungen sich für zwei männer dort im
winter weiß ich dass ich doch nur zwei
extreme
sie ist 17 oder 18
larissa die ältere tochter wohnt nehme
da sie studiert in die lehnt auf der
anderen seite von florida
vor sechs jahren beschließen
juni zum kleid denzer ihr leben auf den
kopf zu stellen damit auch das von punch
und den beiden töchtern der
zwölfjährigen frank unter 15-jährigen
larissa
der hauptgrund für ihre auswanderung
vater kleid
er hat als autoverkäufer genug vom
alltagstrott
als ich im rücklicht morgen nur vom
arbeitsplatz an die städtische arge tu
th größer kick
[Musik]
zum kleid gantzer suchen in florida in
west wie ihre familie mit gemischten
gefühlen
ja unbedingt
2011 ziehen sie in ihr neues zuhause
[Applaus]
der kleinste des tänzer clowns ist von
der neuen bleibe jedenfalls sofort
überzeugt larissa und frankreich
hingegen kann und das ganze noch nicht
so richtig einordnen winzers bauen sich
stück für stück ein neues leben auf
ich weiß natürlich dass diese wegen
kleid denzer sieht das anders
es muss genau dieser hochdruckreiniger
seien fortan bleibt kaum ein winkel des
grundstücks von einem waschgang
verschont
[Applaus]
mit hochdruck gehen sie auch bei ihrem
business ans werk und beim vermieten von
ihrem ferienhaus
[Gelächter]
außerdem kaufen die dancers ein
mehrfamilienhaus namens paul grice
ich freue mich dass ich fix der
amerikaner informiert und die idee ist
eigentlich dass sie damals ohne
rechtsgrund pro monat muss eigentlich
hier als größtes existenz sichert der
staat in florida glück schon bald ziehen
sie in ein größeres haus eine villa mit
allerlei extras
jetzt vier jahre später wieder los
die erste lesung steins auf
[Musik]
wäre eine mega frauen auf dem fuß als er
aus dem grossen ruf die wirklichkeit
ändere
so bleibt mehr geld für wirklich
wichtige zum beispiel fürs studium wurde
larissa für das extra an zusätzlichen
job damit dann mit dem werden können
sagt er aber davon wie die schweiz ist
auch leben nun doch noch wie sicherheit
und eine bedingte diskutiert und gesagt
okay wir müssen wie um verlagern sich
immer wieder nachrichten sowie die
schulbusfahrer suchen
aber der prozess laufe
woran liegt es dass das super flexible
offensive aber die böse fasziniert
[Musik]
denise und begleitet
im moment vom leitet und verwaltet sie
zwei eigene häuser und zwei fremd
[Musik]
die gröbere schäden profi ohne jedoch
wieder im ferienhaus musste bot club
steigt
[Musik]
da kann sich dann auch schon mit drauf
steht dennis und clyde nämlich genau los
ist es komplett verschmutzt haben also
sagen wir uns ein richtig sauber gemacht
das ist ja so eine sache in amerika
handwerk gezielt als ich mir schwierig
wirklich du merkst einfach genau wieso
sachen das bild gefällt
sie lernen das nicht und wenn der
glückliche sieger der handyman herrscher
ordnern oder und jürgen weil das so ist
mit derzeit größtes netzwerk wohl lieb
und gut kennen
und er macht es möglich sie trotzten
lugano zu privathäuser von andere sie zu
sorgen zum beispiel dafür dass der pool
mit zum biotopverbund aber was ist
eigentlich mit dem mehrfamilienhaus
passiert wohin es grund die krumme hätte
er sich
das nur gezielt nur noch obst in das
mehrfamilienhaus 1 verkauft paris es
warmes licht niveau sanfte palmenblätter
raschle schön wär's mir zu sich holt sie
zum alptraum werden und mehr zugenommen
haben ihre jungen ak und und das ist
ganz miserabel kombinationen bis nicht
so viel holz steht unter schock und die
logen das ganz anders gelöst und sie
sagten ja das stimmt
verschreckt poolpartys graben dazu noch
nicht ganz stromzähler wolle der letzten
acht am 23
noch brütet mexiko oder ist es torlos in
paris ist die einfuhr einer sonnenkraft
seit freitag in seinem zimmer
c4-sprengstoff nachdem mehrere hundert
team
was macht sprengstoff
ja denn social die verschiedensten
facetten vom american way of life kennen
gelernt aber sofort vom amerikanischen
lebensstil hat den ist freute wir nachts
dekoration nur mit sauberem schmiedefeld
mit 1 in santa claus zur bundes
familienmitglied
mit mama zocker aber dieses jahr war der
franke liegenschaft ist zeichnet am
liebsten macht sie gerade mit schweizer
landschaft schweiz spielt die 18-jährige
und war so war es doch schon 66 hier ist
einfach für mich
larissa vom ist ja das macht man nicht
so ganz da die langsame
der fonds amerika säcken kulturschock
sie aber jetzt ist der franken wohl fürs
schweizer ist wer nachts florida
ziemlich speziell unterwegs adventsfest
[Musik]
für dynamics
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und wir sind wir pflügen atrophie wir
glauben dass sie besser passt
amerikanische was die kleinen paris
werbetechnisch wenn ich natürlich nur
mit super genial und novum
das ist natürlich nicht so macht es
möglich sehr tolerant und in anderer
sache halt der schweiz exakt das sind
blieben die schweizer männer schweizer
leben
der hauptdarsteller von mahlers 100
punkte ab er wird in kürze krichbaumer
knipsen und auch letzter sekunde
merry christmas
der große schnee warten vergebens aus
der kanone war mit nur bescheidene
styropor überlegt es wird eher kurze
nacht am morgen musste kleid los zu
sieben aperture airbus kritisch aus
spring gestellt und übernimmt die hedge
fonds fordert
die geile schuhe büßt gehöre zum
amerikanischen wetter täglich werde die
der usa mit einer büste 20 millionen
transportiert generieren und so habe ich
mich beworben und 14
das ist durchschnitt in florida aber es
ist ein wichtiges stück für familie
jetzt ist er jeden morgen check machen
mit der checkliste das aussah wie der
honig ist was der vorschrift es kälter
werden
das ist ein stoppball da geht es mit dem
stopp legte das ist kein netter die
lackendorfer das sorgt ein ekzem ist
jeder quasi zwei meter vor dem bus oder
auto stieg und straßen
der schulbus in den usa viel mehr als
transportmittel arena das heiligtum das
uramerikanische
mir macht offenhalten der bus überholen
nicht mal polizei oder krankenwagen mit
der kamera oder sogar für einen film
darüber sind absolut tabu
[Musik]
während begleitet sie morgen tour fertig
machte dennis dafür dass es rund läuft
mit der ferienhäuser dances formierte
team so häufiger mythos nordamerika oder
in florida etwaige überwinden und
blieben meistens gab es aber es gibt
auch viel schweizer wo wie denzel trikot
wir machen
[Musik]
sind ready der dünne ist iris lemmer hat
sich mit dem us wanderer komplett
verändert in der schweiz ist sie 100%
franken überrumpelt mit dem dass er
etwas füllig oder aber ohne oksana krank
sei denn wir machen das ich dass es um
10 ticks
also das sind 10 an den restlichen was
im raum es wäre unmöglich müssen polo
von anarchie ist er hat zum glück mit
seiner seriösen automechaniker
ausbildung vor 100 jahren ein fatales
flicken und machen in die schüco absolut
super mit mit allen handwerklichen nie
mit meinem koffer von 100 jahre gemacht
natürlich begann bereich was momentan
laufen gut wie finanziell auf gott in
nordafrika
dort fuhr mit larissa die ältere tochter
von der nz sie studiert seit anderthalb
jahren an der spitzenuniversität
sie sägen morgenmuffel ziemlich warnt
trotzdem empfand ziemlich am morgen am
juni clarissa studiert nicht nur da
sie wohnt auf dem campus es ist ja
eigentlich dies erst die haie in
freiheit ja ich komme einfach mit
larissa ich die erste idee familie buss
studiert sie an der eliteuniversität
kostet 50 franken auf sehr viel geld
wild leichte kavallerie sah so gut sind
hat das stipendium büro und das mit nur
ein fünftel von der größte träger ihres
linie 10 andere studenten diskutiert ob
das überhaupt studieren
als ich eigentlich dankbar dass sie für
zwei wochen hatte ein anderer schweizer
stadt mit großer bedeutung
auf der pinnwand monik
20 jahre semester studieren
eine nacht im jahr bin ich offen
der schweizer familie gemacht und das
ganze spiel gemacht und sie ihren freund
nicht akzeptiere
[Musik]
larissa sicher zukunft der schweiz gut
vorstellen aber zuerst geht es jetzt nur
mal als msd
ihre ältere kleid und tennis welt zurück
sie sind jetzt stolze bürger vor amerika
und sind das erste mal wählen der
hillary clinton ihre stimme spezielle
person ist nichts wo so eine als als
präsident muss
es ist recht einfach politik hin oder
her den zoos and elexxion schon an
gelernt wer sie der usa wie schafe der
muss ich selber teil versüßen
ein job ist sehr klug fenster sitzt du
vier verschiedene stand bei seriöser
formierte schulbusfahrer ein job der
bootsvermietung und sie formierte
tier.tv fest
fischer feiert jetzt wird es spannend
oder du bist ja eigentlich bikes ivo mit
einer schweizer sicherheit wähler
brechen und sie ist sehr stark über ihre
kinder aber tatsächlich wie vorher
ja webb ist sprich ein und zertrümmerte
das sehe die wasserqualität locker nimmt
hans kraus auf sicherheit aus
gerade doch dass man sagt mir was guide
to how the wakes studierte ich das mal
etikett der ok
das müssen wir es nicht können das
erklärt dass sich hersteller organisiert
worden
die zahle man jetzt die touristik dollar
im monat dass dieser sache also die
gleiche menge her bezüglich sicherheit
staaten alte bekannte wie
hochdruckreiniger ja da gibt es noch
immer der zehnjährige krieg
hochdruckreiniger geräte kein wirkliches
mittel zum zweck selbst luft rein war
über die jedem amerikaner in der garage
natürlich steht gegen wurden
hochdruckreiniger sondern
hochdruckreiniger hat auch ein
romantisches breit und eines großes
herzlich ins feld geschickt
heute sagt von mir lang geht jetzt bist
du aufgeregt macht die musik
häufig den hochdruckreiniger bedienen
[Applaus]
o
sehr viel
daumen hoch nun greifen
reuters
new york weltklasse duo erstens kamera
und einem amerika nicht nur größer als
die oberen
[Musik]
das ist die arbeit für henkels bot
testen wo schlägt worden ist denn das
schafft viel mehr als früher
der unterschied wird physik das mache
sie glücklich und ich als fan zu sein
braucht
da wird die natürliche frauen in der
anfangszeit
[Gelächter]
es ist wahrscheinlich ohnehin muss - ist
in einem rosa tor genau was man wirklich
nicht holen ist zwischen bürgerbüro aus
es ist nicht gut wenn sich die
kreativität um die jobs muss man wieder
weniger werbung schaut das erleben darf
ist dem ich selbst mich so vermachte zu
hause wären bekommt jeder muss wäre
zurückstecken und sagte dass sich die
skat lieblinge zwar mini dahin aber wenn
sie es besser machen muss es akzeptieren
und dem op-tisch natur wichtig punkt
dass man versteht und fanclubs
ja
sobli verändert sich stämme leben für
die teenies und ihren eigenen weg
wenn rätsel so druckte die die letzten
sechs jahre
das ist das spannende verbucht
ich schaue mir ja jene des buhmanns
business und das finde ich spannend vor
dem wo mehr machen wie wir aufgestellt
sie eigentlich ein abo existiert und
hier ist es lieber verbringt ganz
trocken
es ist auch ganz anderes lebensgefühl
das die biografie sowohl die website ist
übrigens leonie was er glaubt als senior
wetter mehr wirklich schöne reisen mehr
nach champagner nicht irgendein gamer
selber kommen von nis unsere bauern
verdienen
das ist schon schutzzielen einfach
fragen auf überleben
dennis und bekleidete amerikanische
traum und auch ihren eigenen willens
bereit sind ganz viel dafür tun
[Musik]
next woche zur idee peter kruse und
monika lennartz kambodscha mit ihrem
geiste hohes kämpfen ums überleben
die machen sich kaputt gegenseitig mit
dass sie krisen zu drucken
als tourguide auf rundreise besseren
peters budget und nimmt sich zwei
ungleiche musste peter bald weg
das geld ausgeht musste peter zurück
schweiz geschaffen
[Musik]
auf und davon spezial wurde ihnen
präsentiert von kinder schokolade